hey martin you brought a map yeah chris
i just came back from a hike which i
logged in the app take a hike
they built a system for logging your
hikes online it is serverless and
exposes data from a cloud sql database
as a rest api in a previous episode we
showed how one can build serverless rest
apis
in this episode we'll see how they made
sure that each user can only access
their own logged hikes
[Music]
anna is a developer working for take a
hike
a service for logging your hikes she
built a rest api
to enable users to track their activity
from a web and mobile app
it turns out it's quite easy to build a
rest api in cloud run
as a bonus cloud run is serverless so
there are no servers to manage
and take a hike will only pay per call
with no fixed costs
anna built the rest api in cloud run as
a proof of concept
now that it's working well she needs to
address security
a user should only be able to view and
edit
their own hikes not those of other users
anna's first thought is that the server
would send the user's id to the web
client
when that user logs in the web client
would then send the user's id back to
the server when accessing the rest api
but there is a problem ana remembers
that one
cannot trust code running on the client
a malicious user could modify the client
code so it sends a different user id
than the one it received from the server
we're back where we started any client
can read any recorded hike
anna does some research and finds
technology that might help
json web tokens or jots
when the client app logs in it gets the
user id from the server
signed by the server the client app then
attaches the json web token
to any rest calls it makes to the server
but anna wonders is there a way to stop
a malicious user from modifying this
token
as part of the jot standard the server
signs all tokens digitally
if the client app modifies the token and
sends it back to the server
the server will know that it was
tampered with it can refuse the call
this means that ana's code that runs on
the server
can trust the user id it gets from the
client
she can use that user id in her sql code
when looking up the user's recorded
hikes
this sounds great in principle but would
it be hard for anna to write this code
she doesn't have any experience with
cryptography
yeah whenever you write security related
code like this
it's best to lean on well-tested
libraries
ivana does that there's less risk of
leaving a security hole open
fortunately she doesn't have to create
the json web token
google's servers do that and when she
decodes the token
she can use a library provided by google
this is really cool
what does the code look like tune into a
future episode
and we'll see anna's code hey martin
where did you hike to uh i
walked over to the refrigerator well i
suppose you can take a long hike next
time
[Music]